the election campaign trail where
anything
with eight weeks to go politicians are
hitting the road and meeting the public
which can be messy
Julian Duffy has first-hand experience
at the chaos of a campaign no absolutely
I'm live now you mustn't be because the
encounter lasted less than five minutes
but Gordon Brown's campaign never
recovered say all the time I've never
voted you know I never I never went top
five years later and its traditional
labor supporters like mrs. Duffy that Ed
Miliband is relying on but watch tells
most famous grandmother is back on side
I've fought in labor
oh really yeah you know I just wanted
like the government said because just
what the coalition it just 24 hours
before Gillian Duffy became a household
name David Cameron had his own
uncomfortable encounter with a father
he was taking his disabled son to
hospital when Jonathan Bartley met David
Cameron in 2010 he was a floating voter
now he's standing for the Green Party
I know politicians are shielded from the
general public and things are deemed to
have gone wrong when a member of the
public unexpectedly confronts a
politician and that speaks volumes in
itself because surely an election
campaign should be about these
unexpected moments it should be about
real people in 2010 Alfie McKenzie was
so passionate about politics he voted
illegally age 14 when his name was put
on the register by mistake so I voted
for the Liberal Democrat candidate I've
been listening to Nick Clegg in the
moments of the
election it seemed well I'm going to be
a student at some point before the next
election and he's advocating free
tuition
today Alfie works as a cleaner to pay
his fees he will still leave University
forty thousand pounds in debt I won't
vote I mean it's not difficult to remain
angry but it's difficult to remain
passionate about change and passionate
about reform when you're having it
beaten out of you day after day after
day after day after day the campaign
trail is a minefield of angry voters the
question is which one of them will
influence the election in 2015 so if you
bridge Sky News